Do you want to play Party Animals on your phone today?
Look,
yes friends
and let the band know
because today Party Animals was finally launched.
But if you don't have a computer,
a console to play it,
don't worry because with the cell phone,
a tablet or the state PC you will be able to play it.
But first,
listen to this,
that this great game
where you will have to choose a small animal
and go out to do mischief on the
is compatible with x,
Xbox's streaming service
that allows you to play online
from any mobile device.
And not only this game,
but also GTA 5,
Starfire and many more.
So you know,
take advantage of
because Xbox Game Pass is cheaper than Doritos
And if you didn't know it,
it's because you don't follow me.
Follow me